Một giảm tiền số thường được khoảng 30,000 bởi sắc bình.
Nhưng này ông vừa bị vắt để điều tra về cáo bục lựa đạo nhà đầu tiêu khi chúng đỏ hơn 30,000 ti đồng.
Bây thủ đoạn được đạo của sắc bình đã thực hiện tiến tế nào.
Ngày, giám được tiền.
Đi, giám.
Theo điều tra, từ tháng 5 ngày không emốt, ông bình chủ tế khó đồng khoảng trị công ty của phần Tập đoàn NXT
và công sự có vốn khoảng 5 ti đồng để phát triển dưới án tiền số 1 text,
từ trên vị bài nền, trong đó ông bình có vốn 2 ti đồng.
Họ thành lập công ty công nghệ Plúc trên Việt Nam,
nhằm giữ kiến bán hột trăm tì đồng tiền số 1 text,
còn tắt là một trăm tị tốt cần đã tị trường, nhằm vi đồng vốn cho dự án tiền số và bị đình từ viên đi tì.
Nhưng thực tế, dự án đi, đi tì chưa tổn tải.
Được tháng 5 ngày không emốt đến tháng 12 ngày không emốt,
khoảng 12 ngày 12 ngày 12 ngày tì tốt cần đã được bán cho 3 ngày nhà đầu tiêu,
phù về bốn phê năm triệu dưới đi tì đồng tiền số, tương đưa 1 trong ngày bài tì đồng.
Quễ năm nay không ai mốt, sắc bình đã sự dùng quy tính và tầm mạnh hưởng của bản thân để đăng tải thông tiền trên mạng sau.
Ông cũng bố thành lập quy đồng tiền nè xuống trong blockchain.
Cám ký rõ 6 trở vì vết đi trong 1 năm vào các giãn blockchain,
trong đó của AnTex đậm thái này được cho là để chẳng sẽ ra tình trạm bán tháo,
để đút bốn khỏi giãn về sự trạm ra trị.
Theo cá buộc, giữ giãn tiền số AnTex trên khai không lũng như lũng,
nhưng ông bình và các cậu đồng nèstec thông nháp đu tiền từ vi tổn của giãn,
số tiền này được chuyển sang vi cán nhân sau đó,
quy đổ thành viên năm đồng để chia nhau một tình tiền tiếp tục được chuyển
vào các công ty trong hệ sĩnh thái nèstec, sự dùng sai mục đích.
Tôi đi ra những nó bịng và tả đối đưa.
Bá sáng lập và đút tiền của Phá mi Bí,
của các nhà đầu tiên triếp bọc của các nhà đầu tiên của tuyên tạm về lớn.
AnTex sau đó gần như không có phát đợp.
Và đến tháng ba hai thông hai ba thì thông báo đầu tiên tháng ráp biết,
biết tắt là ráp cho phép nhà đầu tiên đầu tiên đầu tiên đầu tiên đầu tiên đầu tiên đầu tiên
của tối tiền lệ một nhà nàn Tex bằng một ráp đây là thủ thuật thường thấy trong giới tiền số
và là về lại biểu đồ Rhi Rho Chạt,
nhằm só lịch sự xúc giảm nghiêm trọng.
Nhưng tôi cần mới ráp, cũng là vọc giả chị gần như về không,
hơn một tháng chở lại đây rụ lễn thông tin đoạn mũi ký xưa của giảnh tiền số
anti s, cho răng sắc bình chực tiếp chỉ đảng đút thành khoảng hín giữ án bị sắp,
hiện nhà đầu tiên mất tiền, ngược lại, chống cáo tại biết trên mạng sau hồ,
sắc bình cho răng bình chỉ là nàn nhân,
mất 2,5 trở dưới đi,
đến này, các quan điều tra sắc định có 3 mình yên nạn nhân
sau mới chỉ bốn người nục đơn trình báo,
tổng giả chị kể thải hơn bốn tiền đó.
Và đồng dân, tất, chỉ có thể tham lại coni mốt,
thì có vừa xa đừng mạng cho ai nhà,
vừa tốt, các bạn điểm được được.
Đi đến thế này,
chỉ có bố biệt, chỉ báo,
chỉ bỏ cái đồng dây này,
trong khi chị kể ra,
chỉ đến nằm 2,5 trở điểm,
để giống bỏ giá miếp biệt, chỉ bỏ tại sạm.
Sẵn săng, ông còn vì phạm quy định kể toán trong công tynes lên,
khi chỉ đạo nhân viên làm giảm lời đường.
Chế giấu dân thú, bằng thủ đoạn,
hà giá chị trên hợp đồng một bạn với phép tham,
về thiệt thải đặc biệt lớn trong nân xanh nhà nước,
ngày 4 tháng 11, công an thành phố hạn nổi đã hởi tổ,
tầm giữ sát bình cùng chính bị càng khác về tổ lửa đạo chính bỏ tay sạm
và vì phạm quy định về kể toán về hợp quan nghiêm trọng.
Phu dữ nằm trong chính bị bài kế bà,
mới tham sổ lọng,
2 thông phòng chi trọng xí rân.
Bà,
tỏ kế,
phục phục.
Bà,
nhá,
tựa và tài sẵn giống bỏ tay.
Bà,
tựa.